this box contains three red marbles and
five blue ones and two marbles are drawn
from it what is the probability that
both are of the same color as we saw in
the previous part of the session there
will be two cases here here's the first
one we pick a marble and then pick
another one and in the second case we
pick a marble put it back in and then
pick another one okay so what is asked
we have to find the probability of both
marbles being of the same color let's
discuss the first case of pick and pick
look at the marbles and think of it we
will pick two marbles and both have to
be of the same color so we can pick a
red in a red or a blue and a blue
because there is an or let's write the
plus sign here probability of both being
red plus the probability of both being
blue what is the probability of both
marbles being red there are three red
marbles out of eight the probability of
the first marble being red will be three
over eight and here we are not placing
it back in the box
so now there are two red bubbles and
seven and all the probability of the
second marble being red will be two over
seven this is the probability of both
marbles being red probability of both
marbles being blue there are five blue
marbles out of the total of eight the
probability of the first marble being
blue will be 5 over eight and now there
are four blue marbles out of a total of
seven so the probability of the second
marble also being blue will be 4 over 7
this will give us the answer for the
first case now let's move on to the
second case we pick a marble place it
back in and then pick another one again
there will be two cases here both being
red or both being blue the probability
of picking a red marble is three over
eight then we put it back in and again
the probability of picking a red marble
will be three over eight what will be
the probability of both marbles being
blue the probability of
a blue marble first will be 5 over 8
after putting it back in the box the
probability of picking a blue marble
again will be 5 over 8 this entire thing
is the probability for the second case
in which we put the marble back in
before we pick the second one I hope the
solution was clear both of the same
color might mean that either both are
red or both are blue what if I slightly
modified the question and asked you the
probability of both being of different
colors let's see it on a new page this
is what's asked two marbles are drawn
what will be the probability that both
are of different colors there will be
two cases like we have seen before we
pick one marble and then pick another
one without putting the first one back
in and the second in which we pick one
marble put it back in and then pick
another one what does different colors
mean it might mean that the first marble
we pick is red and the second one is
blue or it might mean that the first one
we pick is blue and the second one is
red let's write the plus sign as there's
an or red first and then blue plus blue
first and then red the probability of
picking a red marble first will be 3
over 8 as we are not putting it back
into the box now there are 5 blue
marbles left out of the total of 7 so
the probability of picking a blue marble
after red one will be 5 over 7 now what
is the probability of picking a blue
marble first it will be 5 over 8 and
then the probability of picking a red
marble will be 3 over 7 this is the
probability for the first case pause the
video and try solving the probability
for the second case there will be two
cases again for the second case red blue
or blue red the probability of picking a
red marble first will be three over
eight and it is put back into the box
now the probability of picking a blue
marble will be 5 over 8
the probability of picking a blue marble
first will be 5 over 8 and after its put
back into the box the probability of
picking a red marble will be 3 over 8 in
your exams you will be asked about just
one of the cases not both it will be
mentioned if the marble is replaced or
not if it is not replaced use the first
case approach and if it is use the
second one